Finally.
Haley.
Hey guys, how's it going?
Fantastic.
Feel like that was a loaded answer.
Okay.
Can you feel 100%?
No B.
He told me well enough, I guess.
I guess so.
Yeah.
I also don't feel like it was very coded.
So maybe you know me well enough where you don't feel the need to code it.
Ninna.
Yeah, no, uh...
Nice job showing the thing earlier.
It's always, it's always tricky.
Kip.
sharing things with that group.
The.
Yeah, it's fine.
They do the same thing to me. Like, I'll show them something and they'll be like, so let me bring up this point of something that, you know.
I would, I...
I think, I don't know, probably they're not listening when I even started that, that rock this quarter. I said, I'm gonna, I'm just gonna take one piece of the pie and work on it.
It maybe, maybe. I mean, realistically, for some people, it doesn't matter how much you preface. They're going to.
PH.
They're gonna...
Yeah, that's fine.
Hear what they're gonna hear.
Yeah, that's true, but you know, it happens and it's okay. Again, that's not the point of the rock. The point of the rock is to actually start it, right? Okay, Robert's here.
Yep, thanks.
Hey, Robert.
Hi, Rob.
I can, I cannot hear nor.
Good afternoon.
De.
Hello.
Yeah.
Ninna.
Okay.
Alright, coming in. You're about to see my face in two seconds.
Alright, coming in about to see my face in two seconds.
I think there's my face.
Hi.
You.
Yeah, we can see you.
Hold on, let me do one more thing.
Sorry, guys, I am.
It's echoey.
Phone's jacked up.
Two.
OK, could somebody say something?
Hello.
Yeah.
All right, we're good. Sorry, guys. I got to log into my phone for audio and my mic, and I log into my PC for the video. One day I'm going to fix my machine, but I work too much to be able to fix my machine, man. Thank you for your patience.
You're much welcome. Anytime, yes.
I can hear and see everybody.
Perfect. So I think you usually see myself, apologies for that, and Marky, but it's rarely that you see Lee, if I'm not mistaken. Have you met him?
I don't think we.
His face does not look familiar.
Yeah.
I was gonna say, I don't think we've met yet. Pleasure to meet you. I'm Marie.
Mmh.
I, yeah, let you introduce yourself, Lee. Go ahead.
Master.
Yeah, sure. So I, unlike Mark Paolo and Andy, I work on the US side of house. I actually head up the dedicated products. So I work directly with Andy on a regular basis, you know, making sure that we are doing the right things to guide behaviors of our technical leads, of our engineers, and of the service overall.
So that's where I sit and I just jumped on to say hello, introduce myself, and be a fly on the wall for the call. That's all. Yeah, pleasure to meet you.
Perfect. So I need to make sure I say all nice things about Andy, is what I heard.
Yeah.
I think so.
I mean...
Weather.
I.
Whether it's true or not, please.
We all, we all try to do that, right?
Yeah.
Nice to meet you, Lee. Welcome. You guys have been doing a fantastic job. I have no complaints. If I did, you guys would hear from me more than once a month. Trust and believe.
Oh, I love to hear that.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah, no, that's a that's a great start.
See, that's a start.
Yeah.
Okay, Marky, take it away.
Okay, so I'm just gonna share my screen.
So Robert, the logo is now the correct one, right?
Perfect. Yeah, it looks like it looked like I think AI probably did it before, right?
All right.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, they does it to me all the time.
All right, so this is for the month of May 2026, monthly service review. So let's start by the agenda. So check-ins, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, way forward, and recap. So before we continue, how are
things going at the moment, Rob, on the organization. Is there anything that we need to know, like updates that we need to cascade to Lawrence or some changes?
Nothing changing that I know of. You know, we're business as usual, just trying to keep everybody happy. I know we've been discussing that probably over the next six months, we'll be migrating to Halo. That'll impact Lawrence, but you know, we can handle the training and all that internally.
Okay.
Um...
But yeah, nothing major, but Lawrence is doing fantastic as usual. Yeah, he's the star. He's the star of our team.
All right, thank you.
Other than myself, of course, who takes all the credit for all the work he does.
Yeah.
In tough job, but somebody got to do it.
Oh.
You.
Yes, Lawrence is amazing. He's proactive. He communicates well. Customers love him. I cannot complain one bit.
It's given.
That's nice. Thank you. So let's move on. So in regards to the highlights performance, again, Lauren successfully met the monthly target of May closing 200 tickets and has received positive feedback from clients. In regards to the daily monitoring, I think we've...
Welcome.
discussed this last month, which is the Avic. Lawrence mentioned that he continues to actively monitor alerts and synchronization issues. He's also steadily building his understanding on the system. I know he's quite new on the system, but he's trying to self-learn in regards to the challenges.
Basically, when he encounters new things, he tries to familiarize and try to learn with it. So he's doing a great job on that. In regards to the happiness, yeah.
Now, keep in mind, he's he he's not new to it; he is the local subject matter expert.
Yeah, but last few days ago, I've talked to him and he said he experienced some new tickets or new issues that... Yeah, so I think that's the learning curve, I think. So, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Oh yeah, there's some pain. Yeah, definitely there's some pain. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No question. Yeah.
Okay, so, uh...
But yes, he's doing fantastic on it. It's A valuable tool. And, you know, he's the guy for now. So we appreciate it. I love Javid too.
I love Ovik, by the way.
Love it.
Yeah, he's getting it to a point where we can actually trust him.
That's that's good to hear.
Is he the is he the only one who's um monitoring Avik or there's other people?
What he's he's not really monitoring it, he's kind of managing it. There's a lot of clients where it's not actually configured correctly.
Two.
But generally from a monitoring perspective, if there's an alert and all, it automatically comes to our board. So he's really managing it.
Mm.
Okay.
Infrastructure, I know.
All right.
Yep.
Okay, next one is happiness. Lawrence has expressed that he's very satisfied with the treatment he's receiving, particularly appreciating Robert's involvement and the support being provided. I'm not sure if it's sugarcoating this, but it should be.
Okay.
The.
This is.
He better be happy. So my approach is, is I work for them, right? That's the bottom line. So if I'm here to serve them, if they need something, I get it for him. I'm glad he's happy. And I would hope that he and I have the relationship where if he wasn't happy, I would know it before seeing these highlights.
But...
Kip.
The.
You know what I'm saying? So, yeah, I'm glad he's happy. I want everybody to...
Mhm.
Um...
Service.
As well as get their money.
True.
I second that.
Right, it's easy. Right, let's make sure you're getting your money and let's make sure you're doing the job. It's really simple. And he comes to work every day and comes, he comes to actually work every day. And I can see it.
Yeah.
Mhm.
work. Yeah, not just a clock in, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, and he keeps me in check as well, so I love it.
Okay, with that being said, the action tracker for the month of June.
The CSAT survey for the month of June for Lawrence.
I, yeah, sometimes I filled that out this morning.
Okay, well, thank you.
Yeah, it's the usual.
Yep, OK.
Yeah, on top of on top of this action tracker, I sent you the Federation listing, Robert, for teams.
Yeah, I saw it.
I just wanted to check in.
I saw it. It's on my it's on my priority list. Congratulations.
Yes.
Yeah.
The.
I made it.
Is it?
But yeah, that's not even, yeah, you have to give me some time on that, but I did see it.
Okay.
Thank you. Yeah, I wear a lot of hats here. It just happens to be that in this meeting, I am the Helpdesk Manager.
Is.
I, yeah, I got a lot of hats.
I got to, yeah, so if you.
It's not personal, you know it's not personal.
It's not, don't worry. But yeah, if you can wireless that for me, be easier to talk than email, so we can take that on.
Yeah.
So, yeah, that's it.
Love it. Yeah, I love it. I don't like talking. I know I pretend like I'm an extrovert on these calls, but...
Vishal.
Love y'all.
It's so hard to imagine.
Yeah.
Wait a minute, wait a minute. You're an introvert in IT? I don't know, man. I don't know.
100%. 100%. But I think I have enough ability to pretend like I'm not an introvert. Hence the reason I was one of the IT folks that could shift into management. That's it.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Kip.
Yep, that's exactly right.
If.
Okay.
Like.
Alright, so.
But yeah, I sent that. I don't know. Yeah, I guess you can update it with the results, but it should be somewhere. Yeah.
I saw it. Yeah, I saw it. It came through. I saw it.
Perfect.
Yeah, thank you for sending.
Thank you. All right, so let's move on to performance analysis. Oops, sorry. Billable utilization report for 2026 of May, billable target is 80%. So overall, with the five-week period, Lawrence demonstrated high consistency.
utilization performance exceeding the set target each week. The highest utilization was recorded in week 5, which is 108%, indicating overcapacity usage or extended effort beyond standard limits. The lowest utilization observed was week 5.
one to four. So I just want to ask Robert, in regards to the utilization that I have recorded, because it was provided to me a few weeks ago by Lawrence. So is this accurate, the information, the utilization that he is providing there?
K.
On the data.
I'm going to say yes, but the context is, you know, the reality is, is he's probably spending 85% of his time on customer stuff. And that other 20% is probably on Auvik or training or something like that, right? So he puts, he shows you all his time, right? And we expect 40 hours a week, right? So do you.
And then...
Yeah, mhm.
Yeah.
Yep.
But I think as far as billable customer facing, it's probably closer to the 80, 85% range.
Yeah, because I've instructed him a month ago in regards to non-billable work. I've asked him to create like an internal ticket so that we can track the non-billables as well.
Yep, so that includes billable and non-billable and training probably as well.
Mhm.
Yeah, okay. All right, thanks.
Yeah.
So yeah, he's, we're not beating him up. Yeah, we're not beating him up.
I hope so, man. I hope so.
Yeah.
Yeah, Nick, I probably suggest next time Marky, the next time that we meet, I would love to see the percentage of how much he spends on training and the admin time coverage of that, as well as the non-billable, so that we can actually see how far is he.
because looking at this, like a 108%, sorry to be the bearer of bad news, but it doesn't happen. 108%, it just can't happen. Yeah, technically, yeah, can't. So try.
Yeah.
Kip.
Yeah, understood.
Yeah, and again, if I knew the context was he was working on tickets the whole time, I would have an issue as well. But yeah, the context, we just need some context surrounding those numbers.
PH.
Mhm.
Mmh.
Because I think this is combined for Bilbo and unbilbo.
Yep, well...
Yeah, it's billable, non-billable, and admin as well.
Yeah.
Because non-billable would be like an internal Omega Court ticket.
True.
Mhm.
Like, Avic is non-billable time.
Yes.
Okay.
So next time, next month that we meet, I would, we would love to see different numbers, but you and I can work on that.
Yeah.
I'm gonna add an unbillable here next month.
And more. Sure.
Yeah, OK.
Thank you.
All right, so ticket closure trend overview, our coverage is May 2026. Goal is 8 tickets closed per day. Highlights over the four week period, Lawrence demonstrated strong and generally stable resolution performance, consistently meeting or exceeding the target.
The highest resolution rate was achieved on week 3, which is 95%, indicating excellent efficiency in closing tickets relative workload, which is 38 versus 36 closed. The lowest resolution rate occurred in week 4 at 80%, aligning exactly with the target. So
All in all, he's meeting the target that we have and he's doing a great job. But Robert, do you have any inputs on this or feedback?
What I'd love to see is that he worked 38 tickets and he closed 36 of them himself, right? So that means those 36 were first time resolution.
Mhm.
And I didn't have to fix those. Or he didn't have to escalate. So, you know, what I see is the customer calls and he fixes it. Right. And I don't discourage escalations. You know, we're perfectly open to, you know, do what we have to do to serve the customer. But I think that reflects a skill set, right, and its familiarity with our clients.
FTR, yes.
Yep.
Mhm.
Okay.
Less noise, less volume.
People happy, that's a people happy.
Exactly.
Well, people happy with us, you know, generally people aren't happy in general. That's a whole different meaning. Definitely, definitely a different meaning.
Um...
Just.
I, I, I stand by the fact that it depends on what point in the day you catch most, most people, most people, yeah.
Yeah.
PH.
Ha.
One 100%.
And if they're caffeinated, that's it.
Yeah.
That, that is also a big, yeah.
Yeah, pretty.
Very important. That's vital. OK, that's very vital.
Reminds me.
Yeah.
People are scary sometimes.
Gotcha. All right, move on.
Yeah, he's meeting, from what I see, he's meeting everything that we want and, you know, I knew that.
The.
Yeah.
Kobe.
Okay. All right, so next one is a way forward. So Lauren plans to review and check the schedules for Azure certifications exam this coming July. So he mentioned that still can update me for those kind of certifications and also the schedule.
because he's just checking his free time so that he can take those certifications. And then next one, Lawrence will be on leave this coming August 14 and 17 due to their wedding anniversary, he said, but he didn't file it yet. He's, I think he's going to convince you.
Okay.
to approve the leaves that you mentioned here.
Nah. No, no, what it is. Here's what it is. Lawrence knows his audience. If he put something on my calendar for August, I would definitely forget. So he's probably going to wait until about two weeks before to let me. And again, we're going to let him do what he needs to do. And I celebrate family. So God bless him on his wedding anniversary.
That's why, because I...
So, if he can take off, we'll be fine.
Yeah.
Okay, and Robert, in regards to the certification for Azure, do you have anything in mind that you can suggest to him or he's the one who's going to decide? It depends on...
I.
Yeah.
That's, yeah, so I'm always...
Oh, I lost your screen. I'm always down for balance, right? So I think he doesn't have any certifications yet. So I know there's that entry level one. I'm 100% in line with that. It's Microsoft. It helps us. It helps him. Right now, as long as it's some kind of Azure cert, we're fine.
I.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Okay, alright, I'm gonna take note of that.
Yeah, my goal is to help us and help himself. So I prefer for him to take something that he's interested in. So everybody wins.
Okay, thank you. Yeah, so Team GPS, so I think Andy already explained this to you. So if you want to, or if you want to have the demo, please reach us, either Andrea or myself or Lee, so that we can assist you better in regards to that.
Welcome.
And then I think we've discussed this last time, but again, I just want to follow up again. Build it live 2026.
Kip.
Uh, are you coming?
Anybody from your team, Robert, coming to build it?
Yeah.
So I pinged my manager's manager and I think he said that we're not, they're not coming. I wouldn't be coming anyway, but I think he said they're not coming.
No.
Yeah.
Um...
Did he say why? I don't know if he actually explains to you why, but...
It's not, it's not, it's not personal. Trust, trust and believe it's not personal.
PH.
I understand, but we could probably do something about it. I have a BOGO, so if you needed two tickets and a price of 1, you let me know.
Okay.
Well, if you could throw in a hotel and an open bar and some VIP tickets to a club in New Jersey, you might shift it.
Yeah.
Joking, but like there's plenty of drinking opportunities that are folded in there that are open bar.
What's funny is, is none of us drink.
Oh yeah, I'm not a big drinker either, but these events are interesting.
Yeah, none of them.
Come on, Lee, convince them, Lee.
No, no, but you know, Robert, totally understood. It's a bummer though, because I'll tell you, so I joined IT by Design about 18 months ago. So my first experience with this event was at this last one in August.
Yeah.
And I've been to, so I've been in IT for 20 years and I've been to Cisco Live, Kaseya Connect, Enable, just dozens over the years. This one's, this one really truly is different.
Yep.
Like the goal of it is not to be a giant sales pitch. The goal of it is, hey, we're all MSPs dealing with the same types of things. How are we getting better? How are we driving to the next stage? And this year in particular, AI is going to be just like every other event. You know, it's going to be top of mind, but unlike every other event,
Yeah.
We're not just going to be pitching you a bunch of tools. We're not just allowing our sponsors to pitch a bunch of tools. It really is like.
you know, come in, let's have a learning session, let's develop actual skills, walk away with tangibles. And then, you know, I think every sponsor that gets a session, they have 5 minutes at the end of their 50-minute session wherein they're allowed to pitch their own product, the entire rest of it.
Yeah.
Is a learning session or a or a value-based session, so...
I'm not really trying to sway my eyes. I just get excited talking about the topic. I understand that you may or may not have, you know, control over who's going or not. But if you guys need anything or you have any questions or want to talk about it in more depth, let me know. I'm more than happy to chat about it and a bunch of us will be there.
Yes.
All good.
OK.
And it's just nice to be able to sit down and and have a have a meal or or whatever with the with the people we're doing this as well, so.
Awesome. Yeah, and I've been to one before. And I, yeah, I have, I don't remember, maybe two years ago, I think it was in Orlando, that might have been 2023 or 2024. And I know Andy's excited to go.
Oh, you have? Awesome.
Okay.
But yeah, my both my CEO and my ops manager are here. I'm going to go confirm. I think it was a Team message tonight. I thought I heard we weren't going, but I'll confirm.
Yeah.
Okay.
And I know it's tough for you in your position or multiple hats to get away, but if you...
Trust me, it won't be me. I give them the freedom to go.
I see. I was gonna say it'd be cool. It'd be cool.
That's all. It'd be cool.
I completely understand. And again, we had a good time and a great experience. It's one of the best conferences I've been to. But I'm 100% sure it's not going to be me. But I'll see what's up with them.
All right, no, totally.
Yeah, yeah.
Understand.
Understood. Thank you. Appreciate you.
No worries.
All right. So I think that's a wrap. And any questions or concerns before we end this catch-up that we have, Robert?
Perfect.
No, I'm good. I'm good, man. I'll circle back to you guys on the confirmation on the conference. But yeah, I'm happy go lucky. We are so excited to have Lawrence on the team and he's amazing.
That's nice to hear and thank you so much as well. So guys, thanks so much.
No worries. And you did a fantastic job, Marky. I know I wasn't going to say Marky, but I'm going to say it twice today.
Ha ha ha!
Ha.
QA.
Ha ha ha.
Thank you. Thank you.
I'm uncomfortable calling a grown mad Marky, but that's fine. I'm working through it. That's a personal problem.
with a logo.
Ha ha ha!
Yeah.
You know, like if you're over two years old, I'm not going to call you Marky.
Okay.
I gotcha.
Haha.
It's like, it sounds like an endearment or something, right?
Robert.
PH.
Robert, I don't know how you, I don't know how you grew up in a similar age to I'm assuming myself and don't think of Marky Mark and the Funky Bunch immediately. And he was a, and he was a grown man when that happened. He might not have been an old man. He was a grown man when that happened.
Right.
Yeah.
Haha.
I, I...
CCC.
Yes, yes.
And I am old enough to remember Marky Mark. I love, I still love him. I think he's awesome.
Mark Wahlberg is pretty great.
I think he's awesome.
Yeah, but you don't call it Marky anymore.
I don't call him at all.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
No, I think he actually, obviously when he grew up, he changed it, you know. And yeah, he's good. I'm surprised he's still around with acting and all that good stuff, but I'm not mad at him.
Okay.
Johal.
Yeah, not just like hanging on either. I mean, he's still like people still like and respect this work. Like he's not, you know, for what he for what he did, you know, he's not the amazing actor, but he's very likable and enjoyable to watch on the screen. Deserves it.
Kip.
Yeah, yep, he's.
Yeah.
Yeah, I see them all the time still.
Das, yeah.
Anyway.
Still acting.
All right, so guys, thanks so much for attending this service call. Have a great day, guys.
No problem.
Yeah, thanks, guys. Yeah, pleasure to meet you, Robert. Catch you soon. Cheers.
Lee, nice to meet you. You guys have a good one.
Alright.
Thanks, Robert. Bye.
Lee.
Yes.